hey did you know that jakie News has a
podcast well it does yeah and if you're
not checking it out well you're not up
to all the all cool hip-hip trends that
we're all talking about on jakey news
don't you want to listen to a podcast
where a bunch of uninformed people talk
about a news article and kind of go
around in circles and don't really
understand what's going on yes well I
know I do
so make sure to rate 5 stars and check
out the JK news podcast it's in the
description box below check it out click
it baby in wish-granting news cemented
by iron man's the best it's just like an
11 year old gift
I used to that was my favorite but I
forgot about that pool that pool set
pulls my favorite now I'm a Batman guy
Batman's cool yeah Barron's don't it
means the most human one that's right
but he's got so much money
it's almost unhuman but that's when we
all want right 5 panthers pretty dope
but kinda sucks he's too perfect I don't
think you're allowed to say that is
white guy what's his name mom I thought
what's his name was so much more
charismatic man Michael B Jordan oh hell
yeah dude I liked his Carrie I finally
saw his movie Michael B Jordan was so
likeable I liked him more than Black
Panther up same here what's the deal man
a pool because his character had way
more of like a story or a pain yeah and
I wanted to see his character make it I
couldn't wait to see him again yeah he
was like the Malcolm X yeah you mean man
Black Panther was like not even more
Luther King he was like just like
perfect Yeah right we're just too
perfect I thought you went I don't like
them anymore
see thank you you could have your own
thoughts - you know I can't I have to
think like you guys I like that one
gorilla King dude he's pretty cool yeah
he was sick looking - oh yeah gorilla
King a subway wizard is granting riders
wishes in New York City oh I want that
what does that look like a homeless man
yeah this is an easy top with the
[ __ ] mean yeah it's easy top with
that star like Mickey Mouse is anybody
would you bring anything but money yeah
oh yeah
what did you wish for yeah what did you
wish for a big-ass the off three wishes
now boom candy dogs fun out you already
have two of those things I want to know
I like an endless amount of it sucked
out washing baby time you got three dogs
you ignore right now tip three wishes go
I like a limited suck yeah imagine
storing a limited horchata I just
imagine like a fountain that you could
just go three wishes
Oh a big-ass farm a jeep with a machine
gun on top where I could shoot the stuff
in my farm with and a slide from my
[ __ ] bed that goes into a big pool
okay I like that's really smells really
fast they're very specific that curves
up 45 degrees and then drops and he
lives thinking of wishes you know what I
mean so unlimited pizza unlimited money
unlimited honey's you know I'm talking
about I don't know I'll tell you that
I'll tell you what right now though
unlimited money already answers all the
other two that's yeah you're right you
can get all the future you want I didn't
think it through
yeah money
yeah you know you can have a limited
home you could have unlimited anything I
could have had two more wishes this is
what I could have had all I got is
unlimited money and hey you guys are too
material we gotta say unlimited love
world peace you already how can i
monetize hope you know you gotta do the
[ __ ] stereotypical Miss Universe [ __ ]
world peace
yes world hunger yes and I look good in
a bikini mm-hmm you know they're taking
that [ __ ] away
yeah that's garbage man they're taking
that [ __ ] away taking water away
so uh the Miss Universe Miss America
water they're not called pageants it's
about the incentive competitions now and
they're taking away the bikini and I
don't really know what the competing
okay why did they need to be in a bikini
anyway because it's a beauty pageant
it's a pageant yeah but my real do you
all about hot bods what are you talking
about Am I yes what does that mean you
love hot bods can you can you explain a
little bit more you love when have I
ever expressed that all the [ __ ] time
I mean example like when we wanted to do
in a JK orgy and you're like I only want
to do with the hottest people on earth
with hot bods you said I don't even care
if I see their face I just want to see
their hot pot I know I want to be in ten
times a day he's got you there I'm not
all about hot bods
I just want to [ __ ] aha yeah but the but
the thing about that is just like if you
take out the bikini competition why
would people watch it thank you
this looks like a bodybuilding show and
they're not it's not a male pageant
anymore now you got to put clothes on
it's like well it's not a bodybuilding
show anymore but they're calling a
competition but what are they competing
for yeah well buddy gives a [ __ ] about
the nice person competition know exactly
I don't care about that they can [ __ ]
make songs out of [ __ ] on empty wine
glasses in shape dude this is like the
American Idol [ __ ] where it's like it's
like you got to introduce introduced
character show them singing but
introduce sob story have to introduce us
or I'm always like can we cut sob story
just like American Idol I just what see
if they're good or not I don't want to
factor sob story in like I know cuz I
just want to see the rejects of American
Idol that's what I wait that's my
favorite part is that I'm oh I can't
wait for the next reject because you see
through the [ __ ] but the masses
don't doesn't see through that they get
invested like oh man his mom is dad both
left them when he was young kid oh I'm
in every but and even if we're talking
about like beauty pageants in general
it's already artificial as [ __ ] so how
you taking out the bikini part doesn't
do anything hi my name is Janine Sal's
wigger and I just want to uh I just want
to say that I love children and I want
to clean up the world shut the [ __ ] up
go back to Zellweger power exactly who
doesn't wanna [ __ ] help the world and
help me I mean I'm a bio Kevin oh you're
not [ __ ]
exactly way this subway wizard here so
name is Devin he's 32 he's not a wizard
name it's a bad wizard name Oh he calls
himself subway wizard I guess I like
subway so he pointed him sexually no the
wizard what if he's like subway this
what see it can we see him
well what's the wizardry about this
thirty-two he looks like an O looks like
a subway no he doesn't look like a
wizard
you needed purple that looks like a
dunce cap on his [ __ ] head good he
looks like a shitty magician not a good
now I know every day that he's in the in
the [ __ ] subway he goes hi I'm the
subway wizard he goes no you're no
that's what everybody says to him a blue
coat a little bit bigger yeah that hat
it's to erect it's got to be a little
bit dangly and soft needs to be [ __ ]
yes and purple in there all right all
right it looks kind of creepy
well he [ __ ] up could he chose the
most [ __ ] like gnome colours on earth
[ __ ] yes it looks me where was it it
was already in here yeah was it in the
first one it wasn't very weird kind of
maybe he's like Merlin is like that [ __ ]
I'm trying to be my own man you know oh
good for him he's breaking them all okay
what's his purpose my name is Mary
wishes name I wanna hear his voice now
yeah so for the past six months he's
been granting wishes to MTA riders for
the J and Q F G and L line Q line [ __ ]
the Q line is what he says there was
this one woman that interacted with him
her name is Carmen she said that she
remember speaking to him and that they
struck a full conversation because they
talked about the whole wizard thing the
whole getup she's like what is their
Comic Con in town and he was like well
I'll grant you a wish on one condition
she was like all right we got the magic
stick first you thought like oh this is
the part where he's gonna ask me for
money she's a dancer right so she
we don't you dance around me she's
yesterday so she wished for us to get a
specific audition yeah so she was
talking to him and she wish or it's for
her to get a specific audition because
she was a dancer and so he told her like
him granting the wish is saying all
right before submitting your tryout
application just do a dance for yourself
that was his wish like prancing the
witch so what she did is that night she
sent in her paperwork and she realized
that she forgot to spellcheck it she was
really stressed she put on music she
danced her heart out of her bedroom and
then she felt compelled to rewrite her
application and put more emotion to it
so she submitted again and then the next
day she landed the audition she didn't
get the part she did get the audition
and so what Devin is saying here is that
what he's offering is a moment to think
about things differently that maybe the
person will take action she's a-gonna
thinking about differently I wish I
wished I should have wish for the role
yeah it's like I didn't get the rug you
didn't wish for the role be rounded yeah
he's Irish that's why he's green he's an
Irish wizard you know the blue one is
the English one ah like Merlin yeah so
he's he works in customer service you
guys are curious
she works in customer service he's the
son of a nuclear physicist the father
and a social worker mother
he's just customer service dude I think
he works in leather-bound books or
something cool like some wizard Ian's
something like ancient yeah it works a
customer servicing that's a really sad
story though his father's a nuclear
physicist that he turned out to be a
customer
he's a subway wizard money and he just
really likes people he works customers
sir I don't think he has a lot of money
if he does answers he works at the call
center but I mean his jobs gonna be
taken away from Filipinos and stuff but
being a wizard is kind of like customer
service so he wants to work more after
work yeah you say that the use of his
magic
is more of like a self-help psychology a
form of self-help site no III like what
he's doing because it's it's kind of
like a placebo where it doesn't make
sense but it's like just dance and then
shake [ __ ] shake your head out of
that perspective or whatever you're in
cuz it's not that important yeah well
you get different well how does he help
out for somebody than like whoa who's
like well what is your wish it's like
I'm really hungry he's like well why
don't you wish for a corned beef hash
wait call me back would ya oh [ __ ] you
guys
[Music]